medical workers in China are stepping up
their efforts to stop the rapid rise of
coronavirus infections spreading
countrywide since Wednesday more than
three and a half thousand new cases have
been officially confirmed in China
taking the total count to 28,000
including a newborn baby who baby I
refers detected remains in lockdown in
provinces reporting the highest rates of
infection supplies have been delivered
by all forms of transport in Japan this
cruise ship is in quarantine after 20
passengers were confirmed to have the
virus
they're in hospital receiving treatment
the rest of the passengers are confined
to the ship there are four people who
are Japanese nationals of the others two
are from the United States two from
Canada one from New Zealand and one from
Taiwan in Hong Kong more than 3,600
people on the world Dreams cruise ship
have been put into quarantine after
passengers on the previous voyage tested
positive for the virus
the ship's medical team is carrying out
mandatory temperature checks on
passengers all cruise ships will be
banned from docking in Hong Kong from
Saturday as the government declares
further restrictions on arrivals Taiwan
is also banning cruise ships in a bid to
stop the virus spreading Hong Kong has
partially closed its borders with
mainland China the bridge linking Hong
Kong with Macau and Zhuhai remains
opened
so is Hong Kong Airport one of the
busiest in Asia from Saturday all
travelers crossing from the mainland to
the city will be quarantined for 14 days
Indonesia announced it too will stop all
arrivals from China the World Health
Organization is sending a quarter of a
million testing kits to affected
countries to try to curb the outbreak
but a shortage of protective gear for
doctors and nurses as well as medical
supplies it's stifling efforts to treat
those already infected and stop the
global spread of the corona virus Sarah
Clark al Jazeera Hong Kong well Adrian
Brown is across all the developments
he's joining us from Hong Kong and it
appears that there is no sign of
coronavirus slowing down despite
the quarantine measures that have been
put in place in China
yes it's fair to say during that China
really remains on a war footing against
this invisible enemy we saw dramatic
pictures on social media unverified
pictures showing streets being sprayed
with disinfectant and also other public
areas being fumigated the narrative
though on state-controlled television is
this China is winning this battle and
will continue to win the battle I think
that window we had several weeks ago
when the media is being very questioning
in its coverage of what was taking place
has now changed I think the government
wants to focus on the positive and less
on the negative the news that China may
well have to postpone its annual session
of Parliament the National People's
Congress in early March is a further
reminder I guess of just how severe the
authorities are now treating this but
certainly the impression you get from
Wuhan today is that hospitals remain
swamped there is an acute shortage of
beds and remember just a few days ago
the Chinese government conceded that it
needed the international community to
help it in terms of sending more
supplies more face masks and in
particular protective medical gear for
workers and what about the quarantine
vessel in the harbor in Hong Kong where
you are what's the latest on that and
how are people there coping well they're
the enforced holiday for the 1800 or so
passengers on board that vessel looks
like it will continue for at least you
know another two weeks they are going to
remain in quarantine as officials from
Hong Kong center for disease prevention
continue doing mandatory checks on
everyone on board now we did have some
good news today concerning about three
crew members who were admitted to
hospital feeling unwell on Wednesday
have been given the all-clear they don't
have the virus but the authorities are
not taking any chances they are
continuing to screen everybody on that
boat and remember that before we realize
that several people had been infected we
know that from a previous voyage when
there was an unfair
several hundred people got off the boat
in Hong Kong just over ten days ago and
the authorities are still looking for
those people as Sarah mentioned in her
report there's been another blow for
Hong Kong today with Taiwan announcing
that it's going to place severe travel
restrictions on people leaving Hong Kong
for Taiwan basically Taiwan's not going
to issue any more visas to people from
Hong Kong or indeed to any foreigners
living here it's all helping to increase
the sense of isolation I think that
people here in China in China and in
Hong Kong are starting to feel all right
Adrian Brown thank you for bringing us
that update from Hong Kong